[Music]
joining me on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line from the worldwide leader in
sports where he is carving himself a
terrific career in broadcasting you'll
see him on nfl live at 4 eastern later
today he's ryan clark how are you ryan
doing well rich how are you i am hanging
in there man uh i i'm i'm wondering what
you thought of last night's thursday
night game and where this leaves the
pittsburgh steelers
uh with only a handful of games left in
this season
yeah i mean it really puts them in a
tough situation you win a huge division
game against the baltimore ravens which
gives you an opportunity to be in the
wild card race and really with the way
the afc north is going if you can string
together some win maybe an opportunity
to contend to win the division but you
go to minnesota a team that just lost to
the detroit lions and you're physically
dominated in the first half and coach
tomlin pointed to it after the game he
said we were jv up front on both sides
of the line of scrimmage and you can't
win football games that way and then you
look at your team and the second half
big ben roethlisberger shows the heart
of a champion he fights to get this team
back in the game and then it's the
immaturity um it's the self-centeredness
it's the selfishness of a guy like chase
claypool who was more interested in
getting the eyes on him because he got a
first down one you're paid to get first
down and you don't have to celebrate
every single one of them you get a first
down in a situation where we've seen
guys like larry fitzgerald who's the
future first ballot hall of famer sprint
to the official hand him the football
and line up in order to get his team
another play but it was more important
to chase claypool that he have eyes on
him that he get to do what he said was
my celebration instead of what the team
needed and then you get a huge play by
harrison smith at the end of the game on
pat friar moves and you don't have an
extra play because of someone else's
selfishness i think that's a hard pill
to swallow if you're another part of
that team if you're a coach or if you're
one of those other 52 players uh who
will be dressed out and so to me
when when i look at that i think that as
an organization this is what the
pittsburgh fielders are now you're a
team that can't be physical and you're a
team that cares more about likes
and more about getting social media
views than you do actually winning
football games that is something else
and uh the irony is that uh claypool and
larry fitzgerald were same number 11 and
it's just
you know um so let's just put a pin in
that for a second
and and kind of hit what you just said
not physical and and and liking you know
needing more likes than actual uh uh
plays on the field uh that is so not
mike tomlin so how does something like
this happen
in pittsburgh you know you know i i used
to attribute it to you know the
generations changing obviously this is a
part of of what life is but i think it's
all about leadership when we were in
pittsburgh we grew up with coach tomlin
coach tomlin was younger than some of
the players on our team you know we had
guys like james ferry you had guys like
uh you know the heinz ward you had true
leaders in the locker room that coach
tomlin could lean on to communicate the
exact same message that he was giving in
front of the rooms on wednesdays
thursdays and fridays to the locker room
i don't think you have that as much
anymore you know when you lose guys like
marquis pouncey ramon foster uh vince
williams some of the dudes who wore the
holdovers from that other era and
you know this kind of started with the
facebook live from antonio brown and i
don't want to harp on antonio brown or
put any
other things or negativity on him but
you think you go from antonio brown
being the leader
in the wide receiver room then it goes
to juju smith schuster who obviously had
the infamous tic toc i guess i'll call
it scandal or tick tocking on the the
logo of other teams in the middle of the
field and then you have the cincinnati
bengals game where von bell blows him up
and it eventually leads to him no longer
doing that and now you go to chase
claypool who if you remember after they
lose to cleveland and get blown out at
home at heinz field in the playoffs is
on social media saying but you're going
to lose to the kansas city chiefs see
the pittsburgh steelers of old they did
their own winning right they did their
own beating right they rectified uh
their own their own challenges but now
this team will let kansas city fix their
problems or let kansas city get their
get back i think it's just a totally
different locker room than it used to be
and no matter what the message is in
front of the room rich if the players
aren't buying into that if the players
aren't communicating and living that
then you don't see it on the grass and i
believe that's what's happening in
pittsburgh right now and coach tomlin
said it itself two weeks ago i don't
believe my message is resonating and
getting through to these guys and so
either the guys have to change or the
way the message is being delivered has
to change ryan clark here on the rich
eisen show so you have had as it was
just established uh a front-row seat to
knucklehead behavior by wide receivers
in in pittsburgh how do you think tomlin
is
handling chase claypool either already
he did it last night or this morning
what do you think he's doing
one thing coach tomlin always does rich
is after the games there's a
select few plays he picks to show the
team and those plays could be good or
bad it could be you know to show what
someone is giving in order for the
pittsburgh steelers to be good or you
know the type of effort someone is
playing with or the type of intelligence
someone is playing with then also those
things
he shows negatively if you're not
hustling if you're not picking up blocks
if you're not tackling whatever it is
and so chase claypool is going to be
made example of
this morning he's going to be pointed
out that one you don't do that from just
an x's and o's football execution
standpoint standpoint right a football
intelligence standpoint like you
understand that you are fighting for
every single second rush the ball to the
referee to the official and then even
then when trey turner is trying to get
the football from him he's upset
and after the game instead of taking
accountability and pointing at himself
that okay it's me he says someone took
the ball from me and that's why we
couldn't get it to the official no you
were celebrating and so i think coach
tomlin will have an opportunity to
present that to the whole team while
presenting it to chase claypool and
sometimes you get a message to everyone
through one person and i think that's
the way that this will be approached uh
with chase claypool in front of the team
but i'm pretty sure he also had a
conversation with him after having to
sit him on the sideline for a bonehead
personal fi after a short first down
catch in the first half
so ryan clark what is the plan do you
think for uh the quarterback spot in
pittsburgh uh you know our your
colleague my former colleague our friend
adam schefter saying big ben's telling
people this is his last year i don't
think that's any surprise the contract
screams that obviously his play
sometimes does too
you just mentioned the locker rooms
change he's got to be looking around
saying what the hell's happening around
here too
so put it all together what is it like
putting aaron rodgers uh jersey on uh
kevin colbert's hope chest i mean what
do you think it is
ryan i'm telling you you know if you
could get a guy like aaron rodgers if
you can get the assets together in order
to do that i think you do that right
away uh if you're aaron rodgers and
you're watching this pittsburgh steeler
team play right now though is that the
place you want to be no i think you know
and i think when you look at chase clay
pool as a player oh you'd love to throw
to him obviously deontay johnson to me
is a young san antonio homes you look
through to him pat friar moved naji
harris you know you have skill players
but you don't have anyone that blocks
right big ben is under siege constantly
it's not necessarily an offense you want
to be a part of and so when i look at
that team i don't know what the next
move is obviously if ben roethlisberger
is still the quarterback of his team
right now they don't feel like they have
the answer in the locker room already or
in the quarterback room already and so
is it draft one of these young guys can
you hope that a kenny pickett falls to
you is he mature enough to take over the
rings leaving from being a pit panther
to being a pittsburgh steeler and so you
have so much to truly weigh when it
comes to making this decision
if you can get a veteran i believe you
do
but i look at pittsburgh as a team that
never wants to rebuild if you start with
a young quarterback i believe you do and
so it'll be very interesting what gm
kevin colbert decides to do once the
off-season starts so
where do you place the vikings in this
grand scheme of the nfc where six and
seven
is right on the outside looking in of
the playoffs worst six and seven team
uh in in i mean the best six and seven
team in in the business or
most disappointing would-be 10-win team
in the business and i'm about to go with
the second one rich i mean matter of
fact look at last night rich you know
they're up 29 points
right this game for all intents and
purposes should be essentially over uh
you have a running back who has to get
gatorade after every carry because
that's how far he gets to run
you know like this dude dalvin cook gets
the ball gets one carry goes to the
sideline because he just got 30 yards
and so you know you're looking at this
game and you're saying okay the
pittsburgh steelers are not competing
but the minnesota vikings have this
incredible talent to make everything
really really hard to allow teams to
make every single game no matter how
well they're playing a close game and
you just can't believe in this team down
the stretch whether it's kirk cousins
throwing interceptions or would be
interceptions when you go back to the
green bay packers or mike zimmer not
managing the clock kickers not making
the kicks that you need
to take leads they find ways to lose
football games and no matter if you're
six and seven if you're seven and six
whatever it is your record is your
record this is a six and seventeen but
it's disappointing because not because
the roster says they should be 10 wins
rich because they've been in position to
actually have 10 wins and they found
ways to lose those games and that's the
difference between championship teams
and teams that don't make the playoffs
at all and right now the minnesota
vikings are team that wouldn't make the
playoffs at all but absolutely should
which team do you trust the most in the
nfc you know we use the that parlance in
our business trusting the most where
you're like okay
uh i think this is the team that's going
to make it even though they might not be
the top seed or maybe the top seed is
the team you trust the most yeah you
know you know it's extremely hard right
because when i look at the resume of
2021 it's like how can you deny the
arizona cardinals this is the team that
wins two out of three games with colt
mccoy
at quarterback without deandre hopkins a
team that's improved so much defensively
they obviously have the most wins in the
nfl a young quarterback that's amazing
but a lot of times
trust comes from history right trust is
something that's earned and when you
look at a team like the tampa bay
buccaneers in the way that they're
playing now offensively with rob
gronkowski back it's hard to not say
that that's your favorite it's hard to
not see a team that now gets carlton
davis back at corner sean murphy bunting
back at corner not seeing that team
improve once mike edwards returns from
his suspension and so when you get you
look down the stretch with the way that
the tampa bay buccaneers are trending
very similar to what it was last year
heading into the playoffs i'd have to
say as far as trust i trust them more
the team i think has been the best team
of 2021 is the arizona card what about
the afc sure looks like the football
gods are winking at us with the bucks
looking like last year and the patriots
looking like brady's first year
there you know like that's no absolutely
absolutely rich i mean
about five weeks ago i was on get up in
the morning and i was like man you know
i was doing my production meeting call
and i thought to myself
and it was a very very solemn thought
rich that really sad me because i'm a
pittsburgh stealer i'm so tired and beat
by the new england patriots i was like
man the patriots can go to the super
bowl and at the time this team was
nowhere near that you know this team was
a team that you know wasn't even in the
wild card position and now they go on
this run of consecutive wins and then
you beat the buffalo bills and you only
throw the football three times this is
the team that's great on defense a
dominant run game and the greatest nfl
coach that's ever lived and a
quarterback who understands his place
and makes the plays he's asked to make
right now i think that's the top team in
afc not just simply by record but by
actual play and film study and the only
thing that's ever going to cause you
to pick against them in the playoffs is
when number 15 from kansas city comes
around and that defense is still playing
well you'll say hey i'll take pat over
mac but right now the new pages to me
are the front runner in the afc last one
for you ryan clark uh you were there on
the day of january 8 2012 in denver
colorado you were not playing because of
your blood condition if i'm not mistaken
back in the day i'm referring to that
playoff game where tim tebow found the
now i can't believe i'm saying the words
late
demaryius thomas on the first ever snap
of the new overtime rules and that's how
the uh broncos beat the steelers that
day what is your recollection
of demarius thomas
one if
you you never met him or talked to him
rich and he didn't have a smile on his
face
uh when he wasn't bringing joy to those
around him and i think that's something
that goes underrated by about a lot of
these these men uh also too if you look
at all the things being posted of them
just so extremely active in the
community i think that was huge but when
you talk about a player i mean powerful
explosive
um quick
great hands strong i mean just truly
everything that now
when we get to the combine we're looking
for in that position and i think for
someone who
was once
so strong uh so athletic to be gone at
33 it truly makes you look at life and
understand it for the fragile thing that
it is
obviously praying for all of his loved
ones for all of his family
and i think he's going to be missed in
ways that
you know
people aren't normally that play this
game it's not going to be about the
plays he made but the people that he's
touched and when you see the outpouring
of love not only from former teammates
but just from his peers in the nfl it
shows you what type of human demaryius
thomas uh you know was and he'll truly
be missed yeah well said and then his
entire career you want to talk about
pressure right i mean
we all talk about your colleague tim
tebow being chosen in the first round of
the draft that year there was a first
round pick before that it was demaryius
thomas and he comes from the school
where
calvin johnson comes from right and he
comes into the league and everyone's
wondering is he really a first round
wide receiver i mean this is way before
first one round wide receivers are the
norm now right now you see four five six
of them and they you put them right in
and you expect them to start getting
thousand-yard seasons right on the spot
and and then you know obviously he
catches that touchdown and then tebow's
gone here comes peyton manning he
catches his first pass right with uh
first reception that manning ever had
with a with a bronco wins his super bowl
i mean it really is remarkable what he
did do in denver and how overlooked it
is in the long run ryan no it truly it
truly is an all-pro pro bowl player yeah
and i think people often forget what
type of offense georgia tech was
georgia tech were in the options they
did
you know so it wasn't like in watching
demaryius thomas you got an opportunity
to see what he truly could be at a wide
receiver and i think that was more of
the questions about him and he answered
those questions every question you had
about him he answered every single one
of them with a resounding yes
and to you know but also for me to to
hear the way all of his teammates speak
about him being a better person than he
was player if you can in any way you
know measure that that means that he was
one heck of a dude well ryan if espn is
still the same operation as when i was
there that means you're on the air and
in about another two minutes for
something else before you do something
else after that something else so i
appreciate that i appreciate that
another something else was this show and
i'd love to do this more often i really
love watching you and uh hearing what
you have to say thank you let me have a
great day you bet right back at you at
realclark25 on twitter you should follow
ryan clark i do he's right here on the
rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here